だ、この考え方の差が人生を分けるんです
よ。毎日の仕事に追われるという状態の中
で[音楽]育成が進まないと組織化でき
ないんですよ。社員の能力をカバーできる
[音楽]ような生産性を上げる仕組みの
ところに投資をした方が私はいいと思い
ますよね。青木サの人生警額100回
[音楽]聞いたら豊かになる話。
今日の質問は青木社長、いつも貴重な学びをありがとうございます。私は
50代のサービス業経営者です。創業して
年、これまでほとんど休まずに働いてきました。しかし最近ある社員にこう言われたのです。社長があんな働き方をしていたら自分たちも休んではいけないと思ってしまうと
うん。
その一言が胸に刺さりました。
自分では背中を見せているつもりでしたが、気づけば無意識のうちに社員にプレッシャーを与えれていたのかもしれません。
改善したいのですが、どうすれば良いか
分かりません。助言をいただきたいです
[音楽]というご質問です。
ま、結局サービス業っていうのはまさに続
的な要素が非常に強くて、ま、どちらかと
いうとお客様に直接接しているクオリティ
ということを考えると、ま、どうしても
自分がせ率戦炊してサービスのや表に立っ
てクオリティをコントロールするという
ところでね、ま、長時間労働特に経営者は
労記法も関係ないから、ま、1番をして
いる中で、やはり販売管理費の中で人件費
が占めるウェイトってのは非常に大きいの
で、どうしても人を雇うその分自分が長
時間働くことによって利益を少しでも確保
しようと、ま、そうなるところがあると
思うんだよね。ま、特に例祭中小企業の
場合はそういう傾向があると思います。で
、1番大事なことは育成ということだと
思うんですよ。育成ということにどれ
ぐらい自分がウェイトをかけてるかって
ことですよね。その自分が働くていうこと
にある意味では酔ってしまうと組織づりと
いうところよりも今目の前の毎日のその
仕事に終われるという状態の中で育成が
進まないと組織化できないんですよ。で、
私も社員5名、資本金500万で38年前
スタートしたわけだけども、やっぱり、ま
、今現在240名の企業体になって、ま、
平均年齢は30.6歳、2027年は
おそらく50名の内定出しを今しようとし
ていますので、ま、ある意味で300人の
規模に2027年にはなっていると思うん
ですけど、で、やっやっぱそれは私自身の
中にそのサービスを提供[鼻息]すると
いうことを組織的にサービスを提供して
いこうという意図があったっていうことだ
と思うんだよね。ま、長時間労働してき
ましたよ、私は。で、年齢と共に少しずつ
育成が進んで
自分がやらなくても良いことはどんどん
社員にやってもらう。
ま、今うちの会社ってのは研修系
コンサルティング会社ですけれども、経営
者教育のところは直接接してるのは私が、
え、3日間の検証をやってますけれども、
ま、日本全国
いわゆる一般のビジネスマンに対する教育
というのは、ま、他のトレーナーが担当し
てますよね。
下にを育てる投資ですよね。人に投資をし
て育成に時間を取ってきた結果、今私が
実際で3日間取っているのは月に1度に
なったわけですよ。ですからこの長期的、
本質的客観的な視点に立った組織運営って
いうことを考えて、え、今から着手し
なければならないと思います。だから中小
例載祭で終わってしまう。それは経営者が
だんだん高齢化してしまって事業証計でき
ないで十分な利益も出ていない。そして
内部流法もない。の連もしっかりとした、
ま、付加価値の高い仕事もできない。
ブランド化できていない。そうなったら
おそらく親族家族しか告げないと思います
。で、それはある意味では中小例載祭載
企業っていうのは基本的にはみんな講師動
どうしても会社そのものがま
して財産も法人名義になっていたりする
こともあるんだけどもやっぱりこの長期的
本質的客観的視点に立って物事を考え個人
ではできないことをするために組織を作る
とこの組式作りという風に考えた時には
やっぱりその働き方改革はトップは何も
する必要はないんだけれども育成にもっと
情熱を注ぐそして社員をもっと物心両面の
豊かな人生に導いていけるように魚を
与えるんじゃなくて釣り方を身けさせて
みんなでたくさんの魚を釣っで、それを
分かち合う方が長期的な視点に立ったら私
は良い人生を歩めるんじゃないかと。直接
的な答えにはなってないようだけれども、
やっぱり物差しだよね。物の考え方の
物差しが目先のことしか考えてないという
現象になるんじゃないかというのが今のご
質問に対する率直な感想です。だ、今から
でも遅くはないので、やっぱり組織づり、
組織化ということを意識して取り組んで
もらいたい。でもそういう時、そういう風
に言うとね、[音楽]いやでもまだ組織化
するほどの十分な材力もないし、時間も
ないしっていう風になるんだよ。だ、この
考え方の差が人生を分けるんですよ。だ、
僕はやっぱり能力の差というのは考え方の
差だと。儲けの差は仕組みの差だと。だ
から自分が働かなければならない状態から
1日も早く人に働いてもらいながら高い
パフォーマンスを生み出せる組織作りに1
日も早く転換するそういうことなんじゃ
ないだろうか。そんな風に思いますけどね
。
その組織化をしてある意味者が働き続けなけれども組織でパフォーマンスを出していく状態を作っていきたいと考えた時にまず最初にやるべきことは経営者がまず今いる社員を育てるということなんでしょうか?それとも採用であったり別のことなんでしょうか?
[音楽]
うん。まず今の社員を育てる、今の社員に不満をまず持たない。
そして自分の経験を例えばマニュアル化
するとか今まなかなかね例祭の場合DX
って言葉では言うのは簡単だけどなかなか
そのシステムそういうITの方になかなか
こう移行するの難しいかもしれないけれど
もやっぱり社員の能力をカバーできるよう
な生産性を上げる仕組みのところにま
難しいかもしれないけど投した方が私は
いいと思いますよね。マニュアルを作ると
か。そしてその次に入ってきた人たちが
育つ。つまり今のメンバーをあるい。育て
るっていうことはマインド面、ノーハウ面
、スキル面。この3つを育てるということ
なんだよね。だからマインドっていうこと
は不平不満を持たないように事実は1つ
解釈は無数で、え、仕事に対する意味付け
、意付け、しっかりと肯定的に感謝の心を
仕事に対しては育てていくってことや、
やっぱり、え、問題解決、課題解決に対し
てお客様お金払うわけだからなんであれ
やっぱり知識は必要なわけですよね。それ
からやっぱり技術を上げるとそういう具体
的なあスキルアップを含めた、ま、
ノーハウもそうだし、時間をかけて育成を
していく。だからそういうマニュアルを
作るというのはこれを見といてって言えば
時間を削減できますよね。からエッセンス
が全部そこに、え、書かれていれば覚えれ
ば言葉で聞くのかマニュアルで覚えるのか
のやっぱり要は知識がなければ同じ
こと巡りするわけでどこに立ち帰えれば
いいのかっていうのはマニュアルがあれば
立ち帰えれるでしょう。そういうことを
しっかりとそれを整えるのが経営じゃない
かなと思いますよね。
だから現場で働くっていうのはそれはやっぱりある程度権限移して社員に働いてもらった方がいいんじゃないかと私はそう考えますけどね。
そうすると働く場所をこう現場からどんどんマネジメント人の育成であったりとか会社の仕組みづりに経営者はもう元々移行していきなさいと。
そういうことだよね。
だから、ま、軽能5大要素で1つは人材の
採用と育成、営業とマーケティングの
仕組みづりが財務、財務戦理はキャッシュ
フローですよね。純宅な資金を半保先を
考えて常に確保できるようにする。ま、
最大の資金の営業なんですけれども、
キャッシュフロー経営をしていく。そして
新規事業開発ですよね。チューメントも
今回スリランカに日本語学校を作ったり、
[鼻息]それからカンボジアに、ま、IT
人材のDX、将来のDXを含め拠点を作っ
たり、視点を作ったり、ま、これからも
どんどんどんどんそういう意味ではアジア
にやはりマーケットもどんどん開拓したり
、本質的長期的、客観的ってこれいつも僕
は同じこと繰り返してるけれど、[鼻息]
そういうやはりこう長期的視点に立った
投資をするとかそういうところがやっぱり
経営者のやっぱり重要なテーマ。そして
あとは技術力、商品力がやっぱり大事なん
ですよ。で、これがね、今のハードワーク
にね、働いてる経営者でも自分なりに日本
一だと自付するぐらいの能力を有してい
たら育成できるんですよ。で、技術力が
自分になくて金儲けのことばっかり考えて
店舗展開してるようなところてはまずダメ
ですね。だからこの経営者がそういう誠実
な姿勢を持って長期的なまあなんだろう。
その育成に対する意識が足りなかっただけ
でお客様満足があるんであればね育成は
可能だと思います。1番何が大事かってお
金を払うサービス業ですから。お金を払う
人が満足してるかどうかが1番大事なこと
なんで。ま、そういう意味ではこれから
いくらでも良くなるんじゃないですか。
この経営者の方は
働きたかったら働きゃいいよ。ただ
ポイントは育成。それだけの人材を育て
なければ一生楽できないのは経営者ですよ
。ただ一生楽できなくてもいいんじゃない
。もし好きな仕事やってんなら。だけど
社員を愛する気持ちがあるならば個人は
有限、組織は無限という言葉は覚えといた
方がいいよ。として長期的、本的、客観的
な視点に立って人の採用と育成そして投資
をし、やっぱり会社のま、ブランディング
も含め価値を高めてかないと結局家族、
親族にしか譲れない。そして家族、親族、
ま、自分の子供さんも本当は他の仕事し
たかったのに親の後を継ぐしかないみたい
な人生になっちゃう。
これはかわいそうだよね。やっぱり
ちゃんと磨いていくってことだと思います
よ。会社を。ま、そういうことを参考にし
ていただければ良いのではないかと思い
ます。私のメッセージを聞いてうん。何か
感じることあればコメント欄にコメントお
願いします。あとあのハイプ是非ね新機能
ですので是非協力してください。
チャンネル登録忘れないようにお願い
いたします。また次回のYouTubeで
会いましょう。よろしくお願いします。
ありがとうございます。
ちなみに青木社長があの私が入社した
年前にはもうあのすにですね、自分が働く時間をも
月けにするってことを秘書にもあの目標に入れてもらっているぐらいの意識で取り組まれていた認識があるんですがこれでいつ頃からその自分のま働く時間を減らし移しま幹部やマネージャー人が育つようにという意図だったと思うんですが
[咳払い]
取り組まれて来られたってご記憶あられますか?
まあ32歳で僕は創業したじゃ
1日16時が働いてました。いや、本当に
、ま、最初は中東採用しかできないし、
速戦力人材っていうことで採用して一緒に
ともかく同じカの飯を食いながらって感じ
かな。で、歩んでいって長期的本石、客観
的な視点に立って新卒に踏み切ったのが、
ま、売上5億、計上利益1億ぐらいの時
ですよね。社員が256名になった時に
新卒作用に踏み切ってだから私はピーク
パフォーマンスっていうコースをずっと今
も大とかっていうのが今そのコースを担当
して私がピークパフォーマンスのコース3
日間やることはないんだけれども昔は私が
全部ピークパフォーマンスやってたんです
よ。ほでフィードバックも全部やって、
コース運営も全部やって、いや本当に考え
てみたら全てやってましたよね。少しずつ
。として、ま、フィールドトレーニングと
言ってトレーニングの中で同席させて見せ
て覚えさせ1部分やってみせやって、え、
やらせてみて、そしてフィードバックし
ながら育てながらで、徐々に徐々に育って
20年ぐらいかけて育てて、それで任せて
、で、今度はそのと、それを任された人間
がまた下を育ててるわけだよね、今。で、
そうやってだんだん組織づりになってって
いう、だから本当に僕が時間的な余裕を
持ったっていうのはかなり後で、ま、特に
うちの場合は研修系の
コンサルティング会社ですから普通の会社
とちょっと違う、より専門性が強いので、
ま、正直60なってからじゃない。だから
今から10年前ですよ。それまではずっと
率戦炊飯じゃないだろうか。ただね、田辺
経営という経営コンサルティング会社が
あって、田辺小一先生っていう方創業者な
んだけど、90歳まで現場におられたと。
年を取って経営のいわゆるお客様と接し
てる人を見て、あんな年まで働きたくない
よっていう人いるんだけど、それはね、
全くね、あの、考え方違います。だから
その仕事をやりたいっていう風に思ってる
ならいいじゃないですか。例えばね、寿司
職人だって80代でも90代でも寿司職員
やる人いるじゃないですか。ま、要はその
人の握る寿司食べたくて来るわけでしょ。
そうなると。だ、僕はいつ引退なのかって
言ったらお客様に満足与えられなくなっ
たら引退でいいんじゃないかと思うよ。
それが本音だよね。ただやっぱり会社系と
考えたら何があるか分からないわけだし、
そういう自分軸でものを考えるだけじゃ
なくて、やっぱり組織化していくっていう
ことを考えないと社員を守れないよね。だ
から僕は少しずつ引いてってるだけなん
ですよ。ま、ようやく、ま、うちも橋本
拓也や高橋谷っていうね、役員が育ってき
て、ま、今次に4グレードとか次にもうね
、育ってる人材がいるのでおそらく40期
、ま、会社を創業して40年目で私は会長
職に、ま、専念できるようになるのかなと
今思ってますけどね。ちょうどいいんじゃ
ないですか。ま、もう72歳になるからね
。と2年も経つとね、気力はまだまだ充実
してるけど、やっぱり体力的には、ま、
普通の70歳より私は10年は若いと思い
ますよ。お酒も飲まないしね、節制してる
から。ただやっぱりね、事実ね、人間って
やっぱおいるんですよ。でもそのおいを
自分ではあまり強く感じてないけれども
やっぱり組織をさらに発展させ、この
ミッションを遂げてくために組織そのもの
を若えらせなきゃいけないっていうか、
もっと言うとキープヤングというか、若い
組織で発展していかないと事業証計が
遅れることになるよね。そういう視点を
持って私はやってるってことですかね。
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容そのものに惚れ込ん
でるかどうかです。
[音楽]